[Musique]
on produit des vidéos avec le territoire
de 50 ans nieline plus précisément avec
le service école supérieur les relations
avec les écoles supérieures sur tout le
territoire de 50 ans en nieline et le
but de ces vidéos c'est tout simplement
bah de montrer de présenter ces écoles
de montrer leurs engagements leurs
valeurs et également bah leur place et
leur implantation au 5 de 50 ans en Niel
c'est des vidéos d'une minute 30 c'est
du contenu hyper rapide très informatif
dans lequel on va voir une personne qui
représente l'école plutôt
l'administration et on va voir également
un point de vue étudiant qui va voilà
parler de la vie étudiante sur son
[Musique]
campus cyess en fait ça fait 36 ans que
c'est implanté sur le territoire de 5 an
libins on est la seule école
d'audiovisuelle du territoire avec un
campus plutôt important tout simplement
l'idée de ce partenariat elle est venue
du service Relations école supérieure de
5 en Eveline qui nous a approché en tant
qu'école d'audiovisuel et qui voulait
tout simplement mettre en valeur
l'ensemble des écoles sur le territoire
de 550 en
[Musique]
Ylin pour l'instant il y a un peu près
un peu plus d'e dizaines de vidéos qui
sont prévu et l'objectif c'est de
couvrir tout le maillage des écoles
supérieures qu'il y a sur le
[Musique]
territoire je suis très content en tant
qu'étudiant de 3IS de travailler sur ce
partenariat parce que ça permet d'être
tout de suite impliqué dans la vie
professionnelle c'est vraiment un des
objectifs de 3IS c'est c'est encore un
nouveau partenariat qu'on qu'on ajoute à
notre liste ça fait des années que sur
le territoire de Saint Eveline on
travaille vraiment en collaboration donc
oui en effet je pense qu'il y aura
encore plein de projets qui nous
attendent et qui attendent bah tous nos
étudiants donc ça risque d'être assez
rempli pour 3IS dans les prochaines
années